bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo où aujourd'hui j'ai mis
mon plus beau t-shirt tyrannosaure parce
qu'on va parler de jurassic fight club
vous avez été nombreux à me demander mon
avis sur jurassique fight club avis que
je ne pouvais pas vous donner parce que
je n'ai jamais regardé un seul épisode
disons que rien qu'à voir les bandes
annonces ça me ça n'avait pas l'air
d'être quelque chose auquel j'allais
être très réceptifs de toute façon mais
bon il faut juger sur pièce donc il faut
regarder il faut voir ce que ça donne
alors du coup bah je vais regarder un
petit épisode de jurassic fight club et
je vais le commenter devant vous il
s'agit de l'épisode 2 les chasseurs de
t-rex parce que quitte à choisir un
épisode au pif autant que ce soit sur
les t-rex et puis il va sans plus
attendre commençons commençons
jurassique fight club
évidemment je suppose que la raison pour
laquelle vous voulez autant devoir
commenter jurassique fight club c'est
parce que vous vous attendez que je dise
effectivement que c'est de la merde je
ne suis pas dupe de cela
oui atone et voilà c'était larry witt me
voilà donc lui ce monsieur là c'est
larry witt meurt donc c'est oui si vous
si vous voulez que je vous fasse des
commentaires dessus c'est que vous vous
attendez à ce que je dise que c'est de
la merde
et le fait est que bas juste à la vue de
la petite bande annonce de départ parce
qu'évidemment c'est juste quelque chose
pour vous mettre en bouche au début avec
à vue de bordes annonce je vois quand
même larry witt meurt en pendant l'intro
et larry witt meurt c'est quand même pas
le dernier des guignols c'est un grand
paléontologues américains qui est
spécialiste notamment des structures de
l'évolution du cerveau et de la cavité
nasale parce que c'est lui qui a
vraiment lancé on va dire la mode de
city scanner les fossiles pour voir ce
qu'il ya dedans donc c'est comme un
scanner médical ainsi this can
sauf que c'est très très très haute
résolution quoi donc
donc on bombarde avec des radiations des
doses des doses de radiation qui
conviennent très bien aux fossiles mais
qui conviendraient beaucoup moins aux
gens quand on essaie de les soigner
mais bref donc voilà c'est tout ce
paradoxe un peu de tout le monde veut me
voir commenté jurassique fight club en
mode vas-y détruit le beauf la bouffe
halle et moi personnellement quand je
vois déjà les trois premières minutes je
vois une intervention de larry witt
meurs je me dis il ya tout n'est
peut-être pas bon acheter ça se trouve
il ya du bon dans dans jurassic fight
club donc et c'est pour ça que ce ne
sera pas un débat engagé pénitence
d'ailleurs c'est parce que j'ai vraiment
aucune idée de ce à quoi m'attendre
ça remplit les deux premières règles de
débogage et pénitence à savoir à savoir
que sa une une audition enfin le
l'audimat on va dire est plus grand que
le mien et le et puis évidemment j'ai
pas envie de le voir parce que j'avais
pas envie de voir jurassique fight club
mais par contre j'ai aucune idée de ce
que je vais pouvoir vous apprendre
pendant cette vidéo donc si ça se trouve
cette vidéo ne verra même pas le jour si
vous voyez ce que je suis en train de
dire c'est que c'est bon j'ai eu des
choses à dire mais si ça se trouve je
n'aurais rien à dire à l'issue de ce
reportage donc bref continuons mais déjà
voilà le début moi je trouve ça bien
d'avoir larry witt nord
ont révélé qu'il était aussi une proie
[Musique]
qui donc ça c'est le plus grand chasseur
du crétacé supérieur
évidemment on a vu un petit crâne de
nano tyrannus donc j'imagine que quand
ils disent le tyrannosaure été une proie
ça va être tyrannosaure au sens très
large l'art de la guerre chez du
dinosaure
très loin dans le temps 65 millions
d'années en arrière la terre est une
planète sauvage vierge et mystérieuse le
théâtre de grands bouleversements et de
transformation radicale comme elle l'a
toujours été reçus mais maintenant nous
connaissons aujourd'hui dans ce qui
deviendra l'amérique du nord
une mer difficile la masse terrestre les
grands mouvements des plaques
tectoniques forme les montagnes
rocheuses à l'ouest et soulèvent les
appalaches à l'est
l'activité volcanique redouble
d'intensité alors je précise que je le
regarde sur dailymotion parce que c'est
le seul endroit où je les trouvais en
france est d'ailleurs au passage c'est
gelé pas acheter exprès pour ça
d'ailleurs je sais même pas où on peut
le trouver
au final jurassique fight club ouais le
lien entre la grande taille et le taux
d'oxygène et pas du tout démontrer ce
genre pas du tout jusqu'à la mort
été 1998 nord-ouest du dakota du sud
en fouillant un site archéologique dans
la région aride des badlands et
paléontologues amateurs font une
découverte extraordinaire
il met au jour les vestiges d'une
bataille sanglante
ils reconnaissent sans difficulté les
restes d'un jeune tyrannosaure
mais ce squelette sort de l'ordinaire
la plupart des os sont cassés et des
dents étrange en forme de lames sont
dispersés tout autour or ces dames ne
sont pas celles d'un petit t-rex elles
appartiennent à un prédateur inconnue
comment ce jeune tyrannosaure est il
mort en 1998 dans le dakota du sud
on a trouvé le squelette d'un dinosaure
djordje est un expert en paléontologie
donc s'ils n'ont pas écrit
paléontologues c'est qu'il ya une bonne
raison
cc c'est probablement un 1/2 c
fouilleurs professionnels qui en fait
n'est pas paléontologue à qui n'est pas
vraiment paléontologues mais qui est
juste un fouilleur qui revend ensuite
les fossiles ce qui est très très
communs en amérique du nord
ciu a été découverte comme ça le
tyranneau anciaux a été découverte comme
ça le tyrannosaure stan qui a été
réservé récemment vendu aux enchères a
aussi été découvert comme ça par des
équipes de des équipes de fouilleurs
professionnels qui sont pas spécialement
diplômés en paléontologie com
alors retrouvé des dents dispersés
autour d'un autour d'une carcasse a
retrouvé des eaux broyé et des étangs
dispersés autour d'une carcasse c'est
pas la preuve du tout d'un d'un combat
c'est la preuve ou d'un combat ou d'un
chat rognage donc c'est déjà on va je
sens que le jeu sans que ce documentaire
a essayé de nous vendre qui a eu un
grand combat là où on a tout au plus ce
prof de charogne âge sachant que avoir
la preuve d'un combat trouvé la preuve
fossilisés d'un combat ça arrive il ya
le combat entre velociraptor et est
restée et proto ceratops pardon qui a
été préservé en mongolie mais voilà faut
c'est vraiment des fossiles qui sont
d'une rareté extrême
on a aussi le combat entre deux
mammouths mal qui a été fossilisé parce
que les deux crétins là ils se sont
encastrés l'un dans l'autre leurs
défenses sont restés coincés et du coup
ils sont morts comme ça quoi c'est une
mort longue et probablement très très
douloureuse et un peu humiliante aussi
mais bref juste trouver des dents et des
os broyés auto enfin juste trouver une
carcasse avec des os broyés des dents le
dire c'est très c'est tout à fait ce qui
arriverait si des crocodiles s'attaquer
à une carcasse charniers quoi c'est pas
une preuve de combat bon donc on va déjà
nous survendre à combat je pense à ce
niveau là
mais le tyrannosaure était au sommet de
la chaîne alimentaire
quel animal était donc capable
d'attaquer ce jeune t-rex et de le tuer
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi qui est
plus gros qu'un jeune t-rex j'ai envie
de dire même des drones et aux orres vu
que si on part du principe que les drom
est aux ordres
charles chasser en groupe même en petit
groupe
il faut un tyrannosaure en train de
courir ça ça fait mal ça sept tonnes de
viande sur deux pattes ça devait pas
courir là non ça marche pas comme ça un
tyrannosaure
et puis si vous voulez en savoir plus
allez voir la vidéo le tyrannosaure ne
court pas donc l'analyse de séquences de
jurassic park ou dans jurassic park on
voit justement que le tyrannosaure ne
court pas et donc j'analyse cette
séquence et je vous explique pourquoi
tyrannosaure ne devait pas courir à ben
vous voyez là on a un scanner et en à
larry witt mais vous voyez la différence
entre notre expert en paléontologie et
larry witt moeurs et que larry witt
moeurs lui il est associé à une
université
tout comme l'ex de tyrannosaure avait
une vision binoculaire ce qui lui
permettait de suivre des yeux une droit
en mouvement en cas d'affrontement il
n'avait aucun mal à garder son
adversaire dans son champ de vision
alors la vision binoculaire c'est quand
on a les deux yeux en face de la tête et
donc on peut voir en trois dimensions ça
a pas grand chose à voir avec le fait de
pouvoir garder sa proie
dans son champ de vision tout le temps
au contraire la vision binoculaire
réduit le champ de vision
parce que les deux yeux ont des champs
de vision qui se chevauchent un cheval
par contre en ayant les yeux sur le côté
de la tête lui par contre il peut garder
ces prédateurs tout le temps dans son
champ de vision
position du prédateur même s'il est
derrière lui donc non la vision
binoculaire c'est l'opposé en fait tu
n'as pas tout le temps il faut que tu
bouges ta tête si tu veux garder tant
tapera dans son champ de vision
c'est pour ça que les hiboux seront la
tête si souple d'ailleurs
ils ont aussi une vision binoculaire
mais ils sont obligés de bouger la tête
à 360° s'ils veulent pouvoir garder
quelque chose dans leur champ de vision
d'ailleurs une vision binoculaire ça ne
se voit pas spécialement sur le cerveau
ça se voit en regardant le crâne et là
on vient de voir le cerveau bleu donc la
représentation avec un cerveau bleu
c'est typique larry witt mres
c'est lui qui a instauré ça donc on sait
qu'on a affaire au travail de larry witt
meurt quand on voit le cerveau bleu
comme on vient de le voir philippe cury
c'est pareil c'est encore un très très
grand nom de la paléontologie donc ils
sont quand même allés chercher des bons
experts pour ce juracie de fight club
donc ce qu'il vous raconte je pensais
pas quand il ya des petites erreurs
passées par là parce que évidemment faux
faut vendre du rêve évidemment mais je
veux dire qu ils n'ont pas pu dire des
conneries philip currie et larry tu
meurs quoi philippe cury c'est un des
grands experts du crétacé d'amérique du
nord et notamment de tyrannosaure c'est
vrai c'est vrai tyrannosaure n'a pas des
dents serrées comme des couteaux c'est
vraiment des roses dans hyper hyper
large et broyage joyeuse dos quoi donc
juste avant on a vu thomas hall ce qui
est aussi un grand expert sur le crétacé
d'amérique du nord déjà là en quelques
minutes en seulement 100 seulement sept
minutes on a quand même l'interview de
au moins trois véritables experts dont
on peut quand on peut sans problème
faire confiance à l'expertisé quoi sur
quatre intervenants c'est pas mal une
morsure mortelle due forme des petits
sillons dans lesquelles les résidus des
précédents repas les compositions devait
produire un grand nombre de bactéries
en d'autres termes le tyrannosaure avec
une hygiène buccale déploré alors là là
ce qu'ils disent est intéressant parce
que avant 2009 ont pensé que ce qui
empoisonnaient la morsure du varan de
komodo
c'étaient les bactéries qu'il avait dans
la bouche mais en 2009 on a découvert
qu'en fait
réellement enfin que le varan de komodo
sécrète réellement du venin est en fait
c'est une découverte qui a été fait en
2009 mais ce reportage là a été publié
en fin été diffusés en 2008 donc il ne
pouvait pas le savoir à l'époque
donc oui c'est une erreur mais non il
pouvait pas le savoir donc c'est pas une
erreur voilà
mais ceci dit c'est très pertinent de
dire que le que le tyrannosaure devait
avoir la bouche complètement moisi de de
viande de viande en décomposition et que
du coup le simple fait de se faire
mordre par un tiret que ça devait déjà
être une garantie de septicémie à séoul
quoi
les plantes fossilisés retrouvé à côté
du squelette révèle que le jeune chienne
axe vivait dans une région de conifères
et de magnolia leur typique du crétacé
il n'y a pas de quoi y'a pas de quoi
s'énerver donc que vous montre des vrais
faux cils le dire on vous montre pas que
des trucs en 3d donc ça ça fait partie
des choses que j'aime bien dans les
reportages c'est que quand on vous dit
un truc on vous montre pourquoi on le
dit comme tout à l'heure la vision
binoculaire il vous montrer une vision
enfin il vous montrer pourquoi la vision
on pense que la vision était binoculaire
on vous montre les images du cerveau qui
montre le nerf optique enfin voilà on
vous dit des choses et on vous montre
pourquoi on les dit donc ça ça c'est
plutôt un très très très bon point une
des raisons principales pour laquelle
j'aime pas sur la terre des dinosaures
c'est parce qu'il vous raconte une
histoire mais vous raconte jamais
pourquoi cette histoire en particulier
mérite d'être racontée et pourquoi cette
histoire en particulier elle réaliste
alors que là il vous montre exactement
pourquoi est ce qu'ils disent est vrai
la peter larsson basse et c'est le gars
qui est qui a fait de la prison quand il
a découvert sioux donc lui c'est lui le
président du black hills institute donc
c'est lui qui a vendu stan ya pas
longtemps et c'est lui qui a fait de la
prison quand il a découvert sioux parce
qu'il l'a déterré illégalement
c'est l'histoire en abrégé un évidement
mais donc lui par exemple ce n'est pas
un paléontologue
c'est un fouilleur professionnelle mais
pas un paléontologue larry martin donc
l' université du kansas ça veut dire que
lui par contre c'est un vrai
paléontologues là sur les intervenants
on a qu on a eu que deux experts entre
guillemets et le reste c'était des vrais
paléontologues donc c'est quand même
c'est quand même une bonne moyenne ce
qui est dommage c'est qu'il leur demande
quand même de dire des sacrés banalité
quoi si tu croises un tueur another tu
vas crever merci ça va ça valait le coup
de faire huit ans d'études et d'avoir 20
ans de carrière pour dire des choses
comme ça ça c'est des trucs qui sont un
peu dommage dans les reportages
sensationnaliste c'est qu'on fait venir
un expert pour ballon d'or mais banalité
qu'un gamin de cinq ans pourraient dire
donc ça par exemple c'est un mauvais
point il ya quand même des mauvais
points je veux dire y'a pas que des bons
points
jusqu'à présent ils accumulent quand
même les bons points ce genre à 6 fight
club mais là on a quand même quelques
mauvais points bon c'est les mauvais
points classique des reportages c'est à
dire on a on est allé chercher le
professeur bidule pour vous dire le
t-rex était redoutable personne sait ce
que ça veut dire redoutable dans ce
contexte mais le t-rex était redoutable
oui alors là alors là on voit des
tyrannosaures se balader en groupe sa
s'est basé sur très très peu de preuves
les des preuves circonstancielles c'est
à dire des squelettes qu'on a retrouvé
de tyrannosauridés ensemble et ça on
n'est pas sûr que ça veut dire qu'ils
vivaient en groupe ça veut pouvoir dire
aussi qu'une rivière a accumulé les
carcasses et on a et on a des empreintes
de pas qui sont parallèles alors on a
deux série d'empreintes de pas
parallèles donc ça fait juste deux t-rex
enfin deux tyrannosauridés ensemble même
pas des t-rex juste 2 tyrannosauridés
ensemble généralement c ou d d'aspretto
aux russes des gangs aux russes ou des
albertosaurus c'est rarement tir
expliqué m donc on a vraiment aucune
idée de city rex se balader en groupe ou
pas on a tout au plus deux individus qui
ont marché côte à côte
préservé par des empreintes de pas
retrouvé en amérique du nord et des
preuves circonstancielles de groupe ii
tyrannosauridés qui ont été retrouvés
ensemble et qui ne sont pas t-rex au la
position des mains en la position des
mains sur les drones et aux or c'est
elle est où c'était laid
ça c'est être l s et es la potion
jurassic park des mânes drôme et aux
orres la soul corps comme ça au lieu
d'être comme celle des oiseaux
d'accord les deux marques de dents sont
trop petites
ça veut pas dire que c'est le tueur ça
veut dire que c'est le mangeur c'est
peut-être juste fait ch a rogné par un
truc plus petit koala en plus le fait de
trouver des dents titre ça veut
peut-être dire qu'il s'est juste fait ch
a rogné par autre chose quoi oui peu
d'ennemis voir aucun l'âge adulte
si et seulement si les petits étaient
protégés par des parents ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas façon si c'est
comme même chez les oiseaux modernes la
mangue et notamment les oiseaux de proie
à la mortalité juvénile et gigantesque
même quand les parents sont la
surveiller c'est pas surprenant qu'un
juvénile se fasse attaquer
donc ça ça participe au build up en fait
d'essayer de je pense que le
couronnement de ce reportage ça va être
un grand combat titanesque entre
dinosaures mais ça ça participe au build
up de ce combat mais la justification
est assez est assez bancale on va dire
regardez le nombre de véritables
ossements qu'on vous montre regarder le
nombre de véritables images de fouilles
qu'on vous montre je dire il vous
arnaque pas ce reportage quand même à ce
niveau là ça c'est ça c'est des images
qui ont été tournées par les
paléontologues même sur le terrain c'est
à dire qu'ils ont des doutes ils sont
allés voir ces paléontologues pour leur
demander leur image aux quoi donc ça
c'est quand même c'est quand même plutôt
cool quoi voyez c'est pas c'est pas un
de ses reportages où on dit aux
paléontologues de revenir sur le terrain
dix ans plus tard et de faire semblant
de fouiller quoi c'est vraiment les
images qui ont été tournées pendant les
fouilles et on voit la différence la
différence aller simple mais je vais
mettre pause parce que c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur mais il ya
beaucoup de reportages où on dit aux
paléontologues de retourner sur le
l'endroit où ils ont fait leur
découverte et de faire semblant de
chercher des fossiles et qu'est-ce
qu'ils font bas soit ils font que
regarder par terre
soit vous les voyez brossé avec unis
prennent un petit pinceau et puis il
brosse un caillou général n'ont même pas
un os d'ailleurs c'est juste un caillou
au pif et il le bros ça c'est pas le
terrain le vrai terrain c'est quand vous
l'avez vu tout à l'heure là il avait un
marteau piqueur ça ça c'est un mec qui
creuse pour trouver du dinosaure avec un
marteau piqueur avec un avec une masse
et un burin voilà parce qu'il faut la
défense et la roche autour du dinosaure
quoi faut éviter de défoncer le
dinosaure évidemment donc on prend une
bonne distance de sécurité mais voilà
c'est ça la différence donc là pour
l'instant le il accumule quand même les
bons points ce jurassique fight club on
est à 15 minutes y'a rien qui m'a fait
faire un facepalm il ya des petits trucs
par ci par là mais c'est parce que je
suis pinailleur puis parce que voilà
faut on va pas donner que des bons
points non plus mais les brefs
c'est quand même plutôt intéressant
quand même comme reportage finalement
ce qu' il est il est honnête avec vous
quand même et il vous montre quel est le
processus hypothético déductive aussi
qui est employé même sillage même si
c'est pas forcément systématiquement le
bon processus
on est d'accord que là ils veulent un
combat alors que bon le chat rognage est
une hypothèse tout à fait alternatives
aux fossiles qu'ils ont mais voilà il
vous montre le processus hypothético
déductive on vous dit pas que le
tyrannosaure à une vision binoculaire
on vous explique pourquoi il a une
vision binoculaire par exemple ça c'est
super cool
on vous explique pas on vous dit pas que
le tyrannosaure broie les eaux où vous
explique pourquoi l'on pense que le
tyrannosaure était un broyeur dos en
vous montrant les dents vous parlant de
la puissance de la mâchoire vous
montrant des des petits des petites
reconstruction numérique bon ce qui est
marrant c'est de voir il ya un petit
brin adn vous ferez gaffe à chaque fois
qu'ils montrent une reconstruction
numérique et un brin adn dans le coin à
droite
je tiens ça sert à rien c'est juste pour
faire scientifique c'est marrant balle
assez intéressant parce qu'un anneau
tyrannus maintenant on sait que enfin on
a de très très fortes présomptions qu'en
fait c'est juste à juvénile de
tyrannosaure pouvait pas le savoir en
2008 puisque la confirmation que nano
tyrannus est un juvénile n'est arrivé
que l'année dernière où cette année je
sais plus mais bref c'est donc à
l'époque qui pouvait pas vraiment savoir
qu'un anneau tyrannus serait en fait
très probablement un juvénile de
tyrannosaurus rex
mais ce qu'il ya quoi que il ya déjà la
controverse au parc préhistorique au
sens très large préhistorique donc il y
avait déjà la controverse en 2008
voyez mark norell encore un très très
grand spécialiste du tyrannosaure et du
crétacé d'amérique
encore un très grand nom de la
paléontologie alors nano tyrannosaurus
un autre j'aime bien c'est qu'ils disent
non au tyrannus mais ils ont écrit nano
tyrannosaurus c'est dommage c'est les
rares bête quoi c'est leurs bêtes
une des choses qui distingue le plus à
la noue tyrannus dati avec sa lutte
ce sont les dents le dinosaure à de
grandes dents compare parfois à des
banales elles sont très aiguisé elles
sont là voyez en vous
on vous explique quand même bien d'où
vient la controverse en fait c'est à
dire que les dents sont très différentes
même si la morphologie en général colle
assez bien entre nano tyrannus et
tyrannosaurus le on vous explique quand
même d'où vient le fait ça avec qu'on a
donné un autre nom un nano tyrannus et
on ait pu teint cette démarche de
l'enfer voilà un mauvais point sur la
modélisation 3d là clairement clairement
ce n'est pas un anneau tyrannus c'est un
culbuto qu'est ya aucun moyen qu'un truc
pareil tiennent debout des traumas donc
au moins ils vous présentent la
controverse voyage c'est encore une fois
encore une fois c'est quand même une
démarche assez honnête exemple c'est ce
que je disais l'aller cerveau bleu c'est
vraiment la signature de la river quoi
puis bal à vouvoyer dit joue cartes sur
table quand ils vous présentent les
preuves que nano tyrannus
enfin il vous présente les éléments qui
font un qui donne à penser que nano
tyrannus n'est pas tyrannosaurus donc on
voit la halle et à l'état l'état des
connaissances en 2008 quoi complet c'est
à dire vous avez l'image de ce qu'ils
disent c'est tyrannosaures et l'image de
ce qu'ils disent c'est pas tyrannosaures
et c'est intéressant gens là c'est très
très bien donc pour l'instant le je
kiffe
moi je kiffe un honnêtement c'est à peu
près la moitié donc c'est à peu près là
que se situerait la pause la pause pipi
la pub et pour l'instant je trouve ça
cool alors là par exemple il dit c'est
clairement une espèce distincte
oui mais lui n'est pas paléontologues
voiliers mais quand c'est les
paléontologues qui parle
on vous dit tout de suite l'épreuve
l'épreuve l'épreuve
voilà ça c'est l'épreuve qu'on aide pour
penser que c'est pas la même espèce et
lui c'est clairement une espèce
différente
oui mais lui par contre il est pas
paléontologues
il mesurait deux mètres 32 euros et plus
de 5 mètres de long et peser environ
il était donc deux fois mardi que le
t-rex tout ça c'est un vue d'oeil
puisqu'on a qu'un crâne
si le dira c'est du pifomètre c'est la
fameuse estimations de taille du corps
au pifomètre dont on parlait dans notre
épisode sur braqué aux russes les pattes
svelte est longue je pense pas qu'en
2008 il avait déjà un squelette
maintenant ils ont ils ont un peu de
postes crânien denanot tyrannus c'est
même ce qui leur a permis d'ailleurs de
déterminer que c'était en fait un
juvénile et très probablement à juvénile
de tyrannosaurus mai mais je pense pas
qu'en 2008 il avait déjà du squelette de
tirs à 2 1 aux tirs amis et là il vient
de vous raconter comment le comment le
nano tyrannus chasser ça c'est direction
du vent ont su sans le dos à quoi ça
c'est du pipeau m ils vont nous parler
des dents les dents qui ont été
retrouvés autour du du cadavre du
juvénile t-rex ils vont juste comparer
les dents et puis ils vont dire que
c'était un homme que sa fille ça
ressemble plus aux dogmes nano tyrannus
je pense que c'est dans cette direction
la convention
voilà pourquoi on n'a retrouvé aucune
trace de morsure sur le squelette du
jeune t-rex l'agresseur n'avait pas les
mâchoires assez musclé mille étant assez
solide pour entamer l'os mais les
vestiges exhumés pendant les fouilles
n'ont pas fini de révéler leurs secrets
aux paléontologues et que j'ai vu les
dents de l'anneau tyrannus dispersés
autour du squelette
ah bin là il va me spoiler la fin vient
de nous dire que c'était bien des dents
de moi j'attendais la comparaison tout
cela alors non ce n'est pas forcément
l'attaquant c'est à dire que tous les
reptiles comme les crocodiles par
exemple ils ont les temps qui se
renouvelle tout le temps donc les dents
elles tombent naturellement c'est pas
forcément un attaquant c'est juste car
voilà ça c'est une bonne question ça
comment on sait que c'est pas juste en
mangeant un cadavre ça va être quoi la
réponse vas-y
[Musique]
ça c'est celle excuses la plus bidon que
j'aie jamais entendue c'est pas non
enfin juste dire juste dire avait le
squelette est pas d en gros l'argument
c'est le squelette nepad est articulé ou
pas trop d articuler donc c'est pas du
charognard
non non le dire à y aller vous balader
dans le serengeti un surtout l'or en
amérique du nord allez vous balader dans
les grandes plaines vous verrez que les
vautours y charogne 100 des cent
disperser les carcasses a pas toutes les
espèces de vautours vu qu'il ya des
vautours qui mangent les eaux mais la
plupart des vautours
ils mangent les carcasses sans les
disperser forcément et vous retrouvez
des squelettes complètement articulé qui
ont été charriés jusqu'à l'os
il ya aucun souci avec ça donc non ça
c'est enfin encore une fois on est dans
une démarche documentaire s'appelle
jurassique fight club donc il faut un
combat à la fin donc il faut une excuse
pour un combat à la fin donc ça c'était
un peu c'est un peu bidon à ce qu'il a
dit mais encore une fois ça fait partie
des intervenants non paléontologues
n'ont chercheurs du panel quoi donc
c'est pas non plus étonnant que ce soit
là qu'on entend de les excuses les plus
bidons j'ai envie de dire faut voir
aussi que c'est un vendeur de fossiles
qui fait ça donc
et enfin le mec il faut qu'ils vendre
son buzz à quoi il ya un léger conflit
d'intérêts plus intelligent
mais le gagnent aux tirs au but n'avait
aucune chance face à dire est que cette
vallée qui pour survivre
là c'est pareil c'est une idée à la con
ce ou bien c'est du char rognage 110
articulations de lapointe
d'après les paléontologues de
tyrannosaure ont affronté un halo
tyrannus et l'un d'entre eux ya laissé
la vie
maintenant il ya deux tyrannosaure où ça
c'est pas et c'est inventer et ça c'est
le résumé d'après la pub le plus féroce
ça c'est pareil c'est le genre c'est le
genre de vocabulaire qu'on retrouve que
dans les documentaires un peu plus tard
clic le plus féroce le plus redoutable
et après on a des gamins de 5 ans ou de
10 de 5 à 10 ans qui nous demandait si
tu es qu'il plus féroce des dinosaures
ça veut dire quoi féroce bon il arrête
de me poser la question une fois que je
leur demande ça veut dire quoi féroce va
voir féroce dans le dictionnaire
et puis après tu me repose la question
raciale a du sens la question différence
ça veut dire méchant alors à ton avis il
était méchant le tyrannosaure banon il
chassait pour manger il était pas mes
chances voilà donc là au moins avec ce
documentaire ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
voit la différence entre la partie qui
est inventé et
la partie qui ne l'est pas j'arrive pas
à baisser le son voilà donc là au moins
avec ce documentaire ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on arrive à voir la différence
entre ce qui est inventé ce qui n'est
pas parce que les partis qui ne sont pas
inventées à chaque fois on vous montre
justement ces trucs là là c'est ces
reconstitutions vous montre les
paléontologues en train de commenter sur
un fossile de nano tyrannus ou de t-rex
alors que les partis qui sont
complètement inventé on vous montre rien
donc au moins vous savez la partie qui
invente et vous savez la partie qui ai
pas inventés contrairement à sur la
terre des dinosaures qui qui ne vous
montre que des trucs inventé parce que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il vous
montre jamais d'où ça sort les idées qui
vous montre donc finalement même si sur
la terre des dinosaures ça a l'air
d'être un documentaire plus sérieux bah
jurassique faut être club ça c'est quand
même un documentaire qui vous donne les
preuves de ce qu'il avance
et quand il ya pas de preuve à ce qu'ils
avancent donc comme par exemple ce
scénario il ya de t-rex et un anneau
tyrannus qui se sont affrontés et que le
nano tyrannus est allé tuer le bébé pour
faire fuir l'adulte enfin je veux dire
cette histoire elle et elle est cette
histoire allait complètement inventé
voilà et ils vous montrent jamais de
preuve de ça parce qu'ils n'en ont
aucune à vous montrer donc au moins vous
en tant que spectateur vous pouvez faire
la différence entre ce qui est
complètement de la fiction et c'est
qu'on est ce qui est du documentaire
contrairement à un docu fiction comme ce
dinosaure ou las vous n'avez aucun moyen
d'y arriver
donc au plus expérimenté ça veut dire
quoi ça ce qui remettre tout ça en
perspective du fait que nano tyrannus
c'est peut-être un gîte nil de t-rex ça
vous montre à quel point ils sont en
train d'essayer de nous survendre le
truc en fait c'est très marrant c'est
très marrant et encore une fois c'est
peter larsson et puis l'autre fouilleurs
professionnels là qui vous disent ça
donc encore une fois c'est à prendre
avec d'énormes pincettes c'est pas les
paléontologues là qui parle c'est les
vendeurs de faux cils enfin les
fouilleurs professionnels slash vendeurs
de faux cils donc encore une fois c'est
à prendre avec des pincettes à chaque
fois que ces deux là il se met à parler
finalement c'est aussi là que le
scénario est le plus mauvais ils ont
vraiment fait l'erreur partout un anneau
tyrannosaurus il est partout
les dents du nano tyrannus sont plus
primitives
voilà ça montre qu'ils n'avaient pas les
mêmes habitudes alimentaires ça montre
pas que les dents du nano tyrannus était
plus primitives donc encore une fois et
encore une fois ça vient pas de la
bouche d'un paléontologue
depuis que le monde mais c'est quand
même très rare que les prédateurs se
battent directement lan avec le train
les combats ça consiste plus en de
l'esbrouffe
quand des combats je veux dire les deux
prédateurs savent très bien que s'ils se
battent il ya de très fortes chances que
ni l'un ni l'autre ne s'en sortent quoi
donc c'est quand même assez rare les
combats entre prédateurs ont finalement
en terme d'expérience ça y est enfin il
nous explique d'où cette idée devant le
nano tyrannus et plus expérimentés c'est
pareil là le mec il vous sort je suis
sûr que le petit tyrannosaure n'aurait
aucune chance face aux nanos tyrannus u2
ou ou tu sors ça encore voilà le voit on
voit très bien la différence en fait
entre les paléontologues qui sont des
chercheurs et les vendeurs qui sont des
commerciaux quoi c'est à dire le mec qui
sait vendre son truc quoi de mais qui
sait vendre son truc c'est un commercial
qui te dit elle regarde l'anneau
tyrannus trop de puissance
ceci n'a rien à voir avec le fait que
j'ai d'autres spécimens de nano tyrannus
à vendre aux enchères
la prochaine fois non je fais un bon
procès d'intention là mais voilà faut
c'est marrant justement de voir dans ce
documentaire là en particulier la
différence entre les chercheurs et les
noms chercheurs voient là et là on
arrive au scénario du combat épique
donc c'est le moment où ça va aller là
j'ai envie de dire que c'est le moment
pour lequel tout le monde est venu me
voir et m'a demandé de debug et ça c'est
parce que c'est le moment foule bullshit
quoi donc évidemment oui le moment du
combat qu'ils vont reconstituer la
grande scène finale de combat entre les
bestioles évidemment que ces foules
bullshit ces foules fiction quoi mais
grâce aux à peu près 30 minutes qu'on a
eue avant on va c'est sa grâce aux 30
minutes qu'on a eue avant vous pouvez
faire la différence entre ce qui est fou
le bullshit est ce qu'il l'est pas c'est
à dire que là le fait qu' à 2
tyrannosaure on en a aucune idée je veux
dire à la base le fait qu'il ya 2
le fait qu'ils sont en famille on n'a
aucune idée
le fait le fait que ce soit un anneau
tyrannus qui les a attaqués ça on sait
pas ce qu'on allait du nano tyrannus est
ce que c'était vraiment une attaque ou
est-ce que c'était du charognard
j'apporte à postériori ça on n'en a
aucune idée c'est peut-être le seul gros
point négatif du truc
que c'est très très mal justifier
pourquoi il pense que c'est une attaque
et pourquoi c'est pas du chat rognage
parce que c'est là nous c'est la non des
articulations du spécimen qui leur fait
dire que ce n'était pas une attaque
d'une je suis presque sûr que cette non
des articulations il aura un peu exagéré
et de deux rampes utah en corse et drôme
et hauser dégueulasse sont vraiment
dégueulasse ces drones aux orres bref et
de 2 voilà il ya le fait que le chat
rognage sa désarticule pas de toute
façon forcément les les squelettes
spécialement quand c'est un petit
dinosaure comme un anneau tyrannus ou un
juvénile de tyrannosaure chi chi
charogne sur une proie donc bon puis si
la proie est relativement fraîche elle
va pas se désarticuler si facilement que
ça quoi
ou des tyrannosaures on en a aucune idée
et ne sont pas présenter de vraies
preuves qu'il se baladait en troupeau
les donc ça c'est pareil vous pouvez
faire la différence
qu'ils aient laissé les petits tout seul
comme ça sans surveillance alors qu'il
ya deux parents c'est complètement con
on sait que les oiseaux actuels il ya
toujours au moins un des parents qui
restent sur le nid on a de bonnes
raisons de croire que chez les
dinosaures c'était pareil parce que on
nage alors je crois que c'est chez ovi
raptor n'a découvert en fait que c'était
un mal
on a découvert des spécimens mâles en
train de couver les nids on a pas mal de
spécimens qui couve dénis chez les
eaux-de-vie raptor et en faisant des
coupes histologiques dans les eaux en
fait ils se sont rendus compte que les
spécimens certains spécimens qui couvait
les eaux n'avait pas d'os médullaire ce
qui veut dire que c'était certainement
des mâles ou des femelles qui ne se
reproduisait pas mais du coup il ya de
fortes chances quand même que les
dinosaures alternait en fait la couv et
des files pas la couv est là parce que
là on parle pas de couvet mais alternait
leur surveillance des petits que ce soit
le lieu où même quand il était jeune
donc si on part du principe qu'il y
avait un soin parentale et qu'ils
vivaient en groupe on peut aussi
raisonnablement faire l'hypothèse que du
coup l'on peut construire cette
hypothèse par dessus une hypothèse voilà
on peut raisonnablement faire la sueur
hypothèse qu'ils n'étaient pas complets
de l'essai les petits sans surveillance
voilà alors levé et alors le petit qui
charge
jamais de la vie jamais de la vie un
juvénile me chargerai un prédateur le
juvénile il va se coucher par terre et
il va faire comme si on l'avait pas il
va faire semblant qu'on ne l'ait pas vu
s'annonce a par contre et c'est parce
que on sert ans et sa part comparaison
avec les espèces modernes et donc encore
une fois faut expliquer d'où ça sort ces
idées là voilà son instinct lui dit de
ne pas bouger exactement
il serait il serait peut-être plus
probablement couché a pas faire de bruit
en espérant qu'on l'ait pas vu mais bon
ne vais jamais de la vie un juvénile le
chargeur peint un prédateur quoi ce que
j'aime bien c'est regarder les
proportions du tyrannosaure juvénile
comparé aux nanos tyrannus en fait tu
lises il voulait tellement il voulait
tellement que nano tyrannus ne ressemble
pas à t-rex que en fait ils ont juste
fait le tyrannosaurus juvénile juste un
adulte de t-rex mais en plus petit c'est
à dire ils ont pris là du ltte t-rex et
ils l'ont juste rétrécit donc ils ont
complètement fou ils ont complètement
laissé de côté la notion d' à lomé tri
alors qu'en fait on sait que les
juvéniles de tyrannosaurus rex même ce
qu'on ne pense pas être des nano
tyrannus donc des vraies juvénile de
tyrannosaurus rex même cela on sait
qu'ils avaient le museau vachement plus
allongée et le crâne général plus
gracile
referme les mâchoires sur le tier l'ex
pour à la moelle épinière
alors ça c'est pareil ils nous ont
expliqué en long en large et en travers
qu'il était incapable de broyer des
zones l'anneau tyrannus ils sont en
contradiction directe avec le ski
viennent de dire et en plus il ya un
autre tir anodin alors que vous semblez
qu'il était mort mais bref le deuxième
petit finalement il n'avait pas tué fils
de charges c'est pareil quand on voit
nano tirage quand on voit la robustesse
du crâne de nano tyrannus il devait pas
chargée
vous préférez les petites dans les
petites dents acérées c'est une
stratégie de type emporte pièce c'est à
dire qu'on va faire une blessure
et puis on va faire une autre blessure
et on va s'écarter et une autre blessure
et on va s'écarter on va emporter des
petits bouts comme ça etc les blessures
qui vont finir par tuer la proie alors
que t-rex lui on est vraiment face à une
stratégie où on a une énorme mâchoire
avec une énorme puissance et des grosses
dents donc on est sur une morsure
gagnante avec t-rex donc nano tyrannus
cette stratégie de chasse tel qu'indiqué
par ses danses étaient plutôt de faire
des petites morsure de s'écarter de se
mettre en sécurité de revenir à la
charge de faire des petites morsure de
s'écarter de nouveau alors que
tyrannosaure lui il était plus sur une
stratégie de une grosse morsure gagnante
mais ça c'est juste par rapport à
l'année tomic on peut dire ça mais du
coup la nano tyrannus qui broie le cou
de son adversaire est qui et qui reste à
côté de son adversaire à longueur de
temps
ca c c'est probablement faux c'est
certainement pas propre aux
tyrannosaures je pense que c'est propre
à toute forme d'animaux qui ont un
instinct maternel
quand bien même ça existe vraiment
l'instinct maternel mais bref c'est
pourquoi tous les animaux qui se sont
fait chier à élever des juvéniles
pendant dix ans et moi ce que je veux
dire quand tu t'es fait chier à élever
un petit pendant plusieurs années et que
tu le vois se faire massacrer par un
anneau tyrannus je pense que quelle que
soit l'espèce à laquelle tu appartiens
nano tyrannus tu as envie de lui faire
la peau
je le pense
alors nano tyrannus qui voit arriver
maman t-rex se cassent ils se cassent ya
pas combat il n'y a pas il va pas
essayer de lui faire face aux il se
casse je veux dire ccc la mangouste
contre le lion la mangusta va pas faire
le mariole face aux lions
on notera aussi l'absence de lèvres
notamment sur le nano tyrannus pour kiel
pour qu'il ait l'air vachement plus
féroce sur l'image vraiment même comparé
aux tyrannosaures je veux dire il n'a
pas du tout du tout de lèvres pour que
les dents soit bien montré bon c'est pas
on sait pas s'il avait des lèvres ou pas
on n'a aucun moyen de savoir et les gens
qui vous disent qu'on sait qu'ils
avaient des lèvres sont des menteurs ou
se trompe parce qu'on sait pas du tout
c'est un débat qui en cours qui en cours
depuis très longtemps et qui restera en
cours tant qu'on n'aura pas trouvé une
vraie belle momie de d'une mâchoire de
théropodes quoi le problème c'est que
les momies qu'on adore les microraptor
et tout ça il préserve pas très bien
cette partie là on a bien les contours
en fait quand on a des mots mis fin
quand on a de la préservation des tissus
monde à bien les contours du corps mais
on n'a pas vraiment le on a pas vraiment
ce qui se passe sur le fossile lui-même
en fait donc il faudrait vraiment une
momie comme les adh rose or qu'on a
découvert les momies à droz or là ce
serait ce serait le pré le prix quoi le
grand prix transmettre un message aux
autres n'est notre ennemie oui alors le
tyrannosaure il avait un cerveau qui
faisait quelques grammes comparé à
plusieurs tonnes je pense pas qu'il
avait la capacité de se dire je vais
envoyer un message
ces mamans t-rex elle aurait défoncé sa
gueule ou tyrannus et l'aurait manger et
puis aussi là donc on nous raconte
l'histoire de nano tyrannus mais du coup
on a quand même des preuves négatif que
ça s'est pas produite c'est que à côté
de ce tir est enfin à côté de ce tir ex
juvénile retrouver avec des danses nano
tyrannus autour de lui on n'a pas
retrouvé la carcasse du nano tyrannus
donc pas de carcasses de la zone
tyrannus c'est quand même une preuve
négative que ceux ci ne s'est pas
produit
donc c'est pas très cohérent non plus
avec les fossiles qu'ils ont trouvé
voilà c'est le scénario classique de
l'extinction se demande un peu pourquoi
le dernier épisode mais parce que j'ai
quand même regardé le dernier épisode
j'ai regardé quels épisodes il y avait
quand même le dernier épisode
apparemment c'est sur l'extinction des
dinosaures puisqu'il s'appelle
armageddon donc pourquoi il ne se paye
de la fin mais bref
donc c'était c'était jurassique fight
club et c'est vachement mieux que ce à
quoi je m'attendais bon pour faire un
résumé rapide de mes impressions pas
déjà lé les mauvais points c'est que
comme ça s'appelle jurassique fight club
il faut absolument que ça se termine par
un combat donc il invente un peu des
circonstances qui vont conduire à un
combat ça et notamment il exclut les
possibilités la possibilité de
charognards un peu vite et un peu
facilement
donc ça c'est évidemment le gros
problème mais bon c'est un problème qui
est récurrent avec les reportages sur
les dinosaures c'est qu'on veut
absolument qu'il se bat et là ça
s'appelle jurassique fight club et ça se
passe au crétacé même pas au jurassique
mais bref d'ailleurs la plupart des
épisodes j'ai cru comprendre se passe au
crétacé à un parent peut-être celui sur
la lauze aux russes mais sinon la
plupart des épisodes se passe au crétacé
c'est plutôt marrant cette volonté du
coup de vouloir absolument surfer sur la
vague jurassic park en donnant un titre
à base de jurassic alors que tout se
passe au crétacé ou presque
on efface aussi et puis bon ça c'est
pour les mauvais points mais après les
bons points c'est que des spécialistes
des vrais donc sur un panel je crois y
avait combien y avait d'intervenants 7,8
fin bref sur un certain nombre
d'intervenants il y en a que deux qui ne
sont pas paléontologue et la
quasi-totalité des trucs
tiré par les cheveux qui sont dit dans
le reportage sont dites par ces deux
protagonistes
donc c'est quand même plutôt bons donc
ça permet quand même de compartimenter
c'est à dire que ceux qui sont rattachés
aux universités vous pouvez croire ce
qu'ils vous disent les deux autres bon
bah voilà c'est c'est plus sujets à
caution
ensuite on a encore dans la catégorie
des bons points il vous montre
clairement d'où sort le scénario qu'on
va vous montrer
c'est à dire que les éléments vraiment
ben voilà pourquoi c'est un anneau
tyrannus parce qu'on a les dents denanot
tyrannus bon même si maintenant on pense
que l'alena stade juvénile de t-rex mais
pourquoi un anneau tyrannus bas parce
qu'on a les dents de nanou tyrannus tout
ça c'est basé sur un fossile qui a
réellement été retrouvé c'est à dire un
juvénile de t-rex avec des noms de nano
tyrannus autour on s'est basé sur un
truc qui a pu se produire même si
l'hypothèse du chat rognage reste à mon
avis a privilégié parce que le chat
rognage ça a lieu beaucoup plus souvent
que les prédateurs qui se frite entre
eux le prédateur ça évite de se friter
de toute façon surtout quand ils sont
juvénile les juvéniles ils vont surtout
pas se battre les juvéniles vont pas
charger comme j'ai dit les juvéniles ils
vont se planquer les juvéniles ils vont
ils vont ils vont tenter de se faire
oublier ils vont appeler à l'aide pour
que maman vienne les chercher voilà et
après vous avez donc les éléments qui
n'ont aucune preuve derrière donc comme
par exemple le fait qu'ils se baladaient
en groupe
bon bah ça je dirais à aucun moment il
vous montre des preuves
donc c c'est une indication qu'il n'y a
pas de preuve
justement le fait que le fait qu'ils
avaient soins parentaux c'est pareil le
fait qu'il y avait deux tirs deux
juvénile je veux dire alors qu'ils ont
retrouvé 15 que let
pourquoi il y aurait eu de juvéniles ci
avec un squelette ça n'a pas de sens
vraiment la fin ça n'a pas de sens de
d'imaginer ça mais c'est des choses pour
lesquelles on vous montre pas de preuves
et de lieux du coup vous avec votre
lecture de spectateurs avertis on va
dire vous pouvez vous dire bon bah voilà
ça on n'a pas montré de preuve c'est
certainement qu du coup ils n'ont pas de
preuve parce que c'est un reportage qui
me montre l'épreuve et c'est ça qui est
important avec les reportages c'est de
montrer les preuves
donc si je devais et c'est là que je
vais vraiment pas me faire des potes
si je devais dire lequel est le mieux
entre sur la terre d
dinosaures et jurassic fight club c'est
jurassique jurassique fight club parce
que au moins il vous montre un docu
fiction ou la partie documentaire et
documentée alors que le docu fiction sur
la terre des dinosaures
on vous montre jamais d'où sort les
trucs qu'on vous qu'il vous montre c'est
à dire vous voyez vous voyez
brachiosaures qui tient sa tête comme un
cou de cygne et ben vous le prenez
content parce qu on vous expliquera
jamais pourquoi on pense qu'ils se
tenait sa tête comme ça et on vous
expliquera jamais la controverse sur la
posture de la tête du bras du
brachiosaure alors que dans jurassic
fight club
on vous montre nano tyrannus et on vous
parle de la controverse sur son identité
on vous dit c'est peut-être un juvénile
de tyrannosaure alors même si leurs
conclusions à eux c'est que c'est pas un
juvénile de tyrannosaure conclusion
après qu'ils vont c'est marrant parce
qu'ils vont ils vont vous montrer du
coup une reconstitution enfin le modèle
3d du tyrannosaure juvénile c'est juste
un adulte modèles réduits quoi alors
c'était pas du tout ça chez les
tyrannosaures mais bref voilà mais même
si leur conclusion est maintenant on le
sait en 2020 n'était pas la bonne ou
probables étaient très probablement pas
la bonne voilà il vous montre quand même
qu'il ya controverse alors que dans
alors que dans le sur la terre des
dinosaures il ya tout un tas de trucs
qui vous montrent qu'ils sont hyper
controversé
et ils vont et puis vous n'entendrez
jamais parlé vous allez prendre ça pour
argent comptant tient papin pam pam
parce que c'est parce qu on vous
expliquera jamais qu'il ya controverse
derrière ça donc la super bon point très
bonne surprise jurassique fenêtre club
je sais pas si je vais aller mater les
autres épisodes parce que de toute façon
comme je le disais je suis pas un très
grand fan de reportages sur les
dinosaures en général en particulier
quand quand il s'agit de mettre juste en
scène des combats de dinosaures mais
très bonne surprise très très bonne
surprise pour le coup jurassique fight
club je suis content que c'était vidéo
ne soient pas des mêmes cages et
pénitence parce que ça n'a pas du tout
été une pénitence
au contraire je suis agréablement
surpris voilà je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo à très bientôt